Her low freak bitches to call this my only master.
The cold is my only teacher.
And the breathing.
When you say you altered your breathing pattern,
it's like,
what do you mean exactly?
Like,
uh,
when I went in at a certain point,
I knew how to be,
you know,
very,
uh,
relaxed.
Go,
went in and done latec a cold car,
impact a go within and then begin breathing deeper and then a certain dance
between the cold and you breathe,
a breath begins to start up,
begins to charge your body.
And after 25 breaths like that,
very conscious in the cold,
the cold is a forest and it has his impact and you go along with a cold and what
it does in the Fisher on the physiology and you use your breathing.
Now I know what happens physiologically,
but then those days it was all by feeling.
And after it does happen physiologically or you become a fully charged,
eh,
the carbon dioxide goes out,
oh to get begins to roam freely throughout the body and fields up every cell and
the Ph levels go up.
Now when you,
when you say you altered your breathing,
we,
what you're showing me here is just breathing in and breathing out.
Like what is split specifically different about that than normal breathing?
Eh,
the way I used it,
uh,
W it was like after 25 breaths,
Eh,
it was so fully charged.
Uh,
I,
I could stay like five to seven minutes under the ice every time.
Very controlled.
And that means that there is not only a whole lot of oxygen inside the body in
the,
but the Ph levels go up.
Now there's a,
later on I began to understand by signs by,
by thinking about it.
And then,
uh,
yeah,
the ducting and all that.
I,
I saw that,
uh,
that we are able to tap into the brainstem,
the adrenaline we showed lying in bed,
people producing more adrenalin.
Now I know how to show to people just in a couple of days.
That means every listener right now is able to do that.
So we have proven this scientifically and it showed that people lying in bed
were able to produce more adrenaline than somebody in fear going for its first
Pankaj jump,
bungee jump.
And when you're still,
I'm still confused as to how you're,
you're doing anything differently other than deep breathing.
You're taking a deep breathe in,
deep breathe out.
And now we retained from breathing after exhalation.
Retent uh,
we stopped breathing after acceleration.
Breathe in like,
well,
show me the method,
like if a view,
if you'll go with me all right at 30 times.
Okay,
go foully and we're once again fully in letting go
right on fully and but Latin go,
not fully out chess in Europe,
but fully yet.
Once again,
I want it to go,
come on,
don't hesitate.
Give it.
It's about changing the chemistry right now in your body.
So I'm breathing.
If you keep going,
you'll be cut.
Become lightheaded.
And at a certain point you're so fully charged and ph levels go to a very high
level.
You're able to stay without eh,
in the long four minutes.
Okay.
Just keep on that feeling is understanding.
Go on,
Andy.
Plan lighting go deeply yet letting go deeply in and go 10 times more deeply in
that didn't go deeply in letting go.
I'm going to time it laddering,
go deeply and daddy go have it fully.
Take him in,
letting go.
Take Command,
letting and go take him in ladder and go,
no hesitation.
I do this with the ovary and Matt as well and it feels wonderful.
Day Command.
Who are they?
Letting go.
Okay,
five times more deeply and letting go.
Letting go deeply and let it go two times more.
Letting go and stop.
Okay,
just top witness without and the lungs.
You are able to stay much more than normally that normally.
Why?
Because we change.
He'll chemistry.
Carbon dioxide went out,
oh two went up,
failed up,
all the sounds and the Ph levels go up.
Then we are able to tap into their central nervous system and that Dan,
that we got the brainstem and that's the place of the pineal gland.
Hypothalamus,
pituitary gland and the pineal gland makes the secretion of Adrenalin in
dangerous situations.
Normally we do not get into it because of of our shallow breathing,
but this is the way to get into the most primitive part of the reptilian brain
without many and fend off bacteria getting better into the endocrine systems.
We talk about it later,
you know pastor one one 10 in minutes and you're still on.
That shows that the capacity to fail yourself up with the oxygen,
there's a lot more than we normally use and as we do not use it,
we are not making use of the full capacity of our faith physiology.
Now we found out we got a different layers and we never use it and this is the
way to learn to use it to tap in and bang into the primitive brain,
into the endocrine systems,
immune systems,
the way nature has mandate to be.
Everybody is able to do it one 45 and this is only round one.
If it would do like three rounds,
you would go to three minutes,
four minutes without air,
without training.
It only shows the capacity to store up oxygen inside.
We never use that.
You're doing great.
He is doing already to two five almost to 10 whenever you feel the urge to
breathe,
you don't need to.
Force is only learning how to Oksana Joey's the body and the oldest south.
You're going Greg,
man,
now he's a field.
Good,
Huh?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
That's okay.
Two 30 Oh
yeah.
When you feel the urge to breathe,
you breathe in fully and keep it for 10 15 seconds,
then that's one round.
Boolean.
And keep it.
And how will you press your belly?
The neck and then the hat
and now you are able to tap into the brainstem.
Yeah,
yeah.
That's him.
If we would do it again,
you would.
Yeah.
No,
it was very light headed.
What's interesting is that breathing the breathing in for sure.
So w w two to explain to people at home,
what I'm doing is I'm breathing in all the ways is deeply as I can,
but I'm not breathing out all the way.
Yeah.
I'm just breathing out a little bit and then I'm breathing in more and I'm just
reading out a little bit and I'm breathing in more and breathing out a little
bit.
Yes.
And if you breathe,
breathe in completely,
you got all the oxygen possible inside.
If you're just allowed to go,
then you get to,
uh,
where the exchange of the gasses happen.
And this is the way a bass to Oksana [inaudible] the body.
So,
uh,
it's a different way to get into the chemistry of the body and where we have
shown this.
Okay.